[音楽]
[拍手]
ああああああ
のことができる牛があるからだろう
true ん
これは1997ん
ゴールドマン環境所を受賞した
thin 言葉デー
私たちの
大量7
大量標準者3人
警鐘を鳴らしたもので
ん
私は現在も仕事で
答弁書がしなっ
年後パーシーものを作り出しています
これどうナビもを考えていました
私が投影とデータ品名
既存プレイヤーを始めた
ては
ワール6人かいたんです
この依頼内容か
ng が容易な場所で
何が研究を行なっ当時
というものでした
さきほども言いましたなぁ
私は仕事で
ものを作っては
というその繰り返し c
疑問から抜けました
実がせっかく海が2台ためなかな
今までの
ものを作り上げるような
何かをリサイクルして
作ることができないかな
同課は傘
そこで目に留まったのが
ということで隠し
費用はああ
体がなくなれば
ただおいドイツしているだからん
僕もよくなくん
日には
日本鉱業みかっ
ジッター
か定められるね
メーカーが異なっても
ほとんど形状同じなく
で例えばん
素材ときて面白いかも
時々
私はこれを使って何か作れない
とかも始めました
そして実際迫力ください
[音楽]
偽サイトやって
最初を3つが困りごとを設けます
一つ目は
金曜ならないということ
日には脳も種類あって
いろんなような
だからはありがとうございました
銅地金支えているものはんが
それらをそのまま使っています
二つ目は神の裁断方法を決めた
c は潰れた状態から再発な
金の中心から文革放流タイガーというわけ
するとを
端っこも言えるわけない
最大が起きたはの部分ん
最小の日かは from 御用聞き
時にてい
3つ目は
リサイクラーたとして
捜索をする際の
極力ボーイをな様
この3つがとな用途を守って作っ
代表からなっ
23 a 弱っ
という違法で便利
インターレイルのは
現代アートを注文した
空間全体を作品として体験させる花
をなくさ国の低迷しても
著書や表明が変わると
見え方が感じ方のかなく
やっていろんなところで兼業して気づいたことがあります
以前カイナーで原料た時に思ったのです
桃園とペーパーの被覆
うんわかっ
経費や言語をとなる
あっていません
共感しやすい
アートを身近に感じながら感動してもらう
でも
そんな身近に感じがあるならん
思えなくてもあり
源氏かよっ
作り方降りろちゃいます
ワークショップを行ってほしい
という声
とても行なっ
興味を持ってください
とてもうれしい
でも私は額
何かあった
うぉっ
私は作品を通してい
大学が深いため
と輝くん
作品を観て感動するだけでばいい
その感動にサイトっ
経営学とのことができな
[音楽]
そこから私なぁとはあ
参加があ
遠い方で倒錯者バッ
[音楽]
三角あることはそのまま等
企業を集めてください
捜索に参加していただき
4日
私の作品は
hiro を集めてください方
でもを
今込めながらべれば
という意思じゃ
た国向けがあるのです
い財布ということを紹介してくださった方に
ここを
初女さんのご照明をいただく
あと l ん
決まるのと思っ
参加型坊
企業を集めてくださいという方を
始めていない方々の
アプリンを等
リサイクルの意識が伝わらぬ
visa カードというと
何か環境問題に関心があるのではないか
お前はこと思う
今回スピーカーとして
登壇することになった
立っ
環境戻って花
と言われました
正直なんです
私は
環境問題そこまで関心が無かっ
です出さなあとずっとん
その環境もうだというキーワードがかかっていた
まずは日本
展示会よねー
の接着には
委細ぐるみんや天然素材が使われている
会えたことを思い出さん
[拍手]
そうの設定あればクルーガーん
プラスチックを動かしてい
生格というものを使っ
[音楽]
何か展望灯台は接着できるはない
大阪じゃいます
そこで見つけたの瀬尾てー
セロテープは
発売当初から
ほぼ全瞑想である
関東によっ
燃えるも見といて組んでい
そのことにより付いてか
今回私は
環境に優しい新しい味作り
というわけでみなさんん
環境問題について解決に長いというわけではない
私の作品を通してい
そういった問題があ
広がること可能だとっ
ああああああん
私の後変えようと思った
今回のテーマ
可能に例えると
スタッフがなました
タッパー一度だけのかな本当
私の中で響き続けだけかな
誰かの人事を焼く
漠然とした疑問や方はありません
解決に導くことがあります
私は作品を作り続けることである
その解決の気づきとなるか
金ノートを
ないけれど a
とった
ていました
ああああああ
[拍手]